all right so I present to you with peace
and love
and a word of warning the latest 538
estimates for the Senate and for the
house for these midterm elections now
there are so many different caveats and
important things to talk about but let
me give you the numbers first in the
Senate
the 5 38 forecast now puts it at a 68
chance that Democrats hold control of
the Senate that is greater than a two to
one margin now
things that are 32 percent likely to
happen happen all the time so so we we
can't count out Republicans in the
Senate it is 68 to 32 in terms of
likelihood of controlling the Senate
based on the 538 forecast over in the
house it is a 24 chance that Democrats
hold the House of Representatives it's
roughly we could say a three to one
margin by which Republicans are expected
to hold the house now I want to remind
you guys this doesn't mean Republicans
are expected to hold 76 percent of the
seats in fact not at all it's expected
to be a relatively small margin if
Republicans win but Republicans are
favored to win the house by any margin
by roughly three to one now there are
many important things to talk about here
first and foremost both of these numbers
the Democratic odds in the Senate and
the Democratic odds in the house have
been climbing over time you might
remember that some months ago on the
Senate side it was like a 52 percent
chance that Democrats were going to hold
the Senate that's basically a coin flip
that has steadily climbed and climbed
and climbed it got to two to one a few
days ago and it has now gone beyond two
to one so the momentum is absolutely
there in terms of Democrats now they're
not going to get 60 seats Democrats are
not going to get 60 seats so in some
sense it's kind of an academic question
whether Democrats if they do hold the
Senate will have somewhere between a 50
50 majority with Kamala Harris as the
51st high-breaking vote up to some
number under 60 Senators 60 is important
because there are some measures in the
Senate where you need 60 votes the
simple majority isn't enough
Democrats are not going to get 60.
there's I've I don't see any path for
that so it is almost certainly going to
be a situation where in order to get
things done Democrats on many issues are
going to need some Republican votes
obviously it's better to only need four
Republican votes than ten
no doubt about that but that's where
we're kind of operating a very narrow
margin now over in the house when you
just look at the house numbers and you
see oh man three to one margin
Republicans are expected to hold just a
couple of months ago the Democratic
Democratic odds were far lower I think
they were around 16 17 or 18 so the
shift from 17 to 24
in terms of the sheer raw numbers is not
significant but 7 over 17 you're talking
about a roughly 40 percent increase in
the odds that Democrats hold still
favored to lose but a significant change
what isn't reflected in these numbers
Democratic over performance and
Democratic electorate uh over
representation in other words turnout
and what we have seen now in Michigan
and in New York and in Alaska is that
the polls did not reflect a correct
weighting on the basis of democratic
enthusiasm and we've talked before about
a number of the different reasons for
this enthusiasm part of it includes yes
the overturning of Roe v Wade by this
right-wing Supreme Court part of it
includes Republican inaction on gun
safety although over the last month
that's probably faded a little bit in
people's minds and the very dramatic
shift in all of a sudden the Maga right
is in massive legal trouble Trump might
be getting indicted Republican Civil War
all of these different things and on the
on the Democratic side
things are quite calm Joe Biden is
racking up legislative accomplishments
The Pact act the inflation reduction act
infrastructure a very good jobs report
we are essentially at full employment
wages are up inflation is down gas
prices are down and all of a sudden
there are people who are saying what is
the choice here a party in disarray soon
facing indictments the Republican party
or Joe Biden who is very quietly gotten
a bunch of things done student loan debt
forgiveness now coming uh people talking
about maybe something on cannabis etc
etc that is not reflected in the numbers
and so while historically this should be
a very bad election for Democrats it's
increasingly looking less and less bad
we're going to continue following the
numbers and I hope you'll join me
tonight uh roughly 7 P.M Eastern for Joe
Biden's address to the nation I think it
will be very interesting I will be live
on YouTube twitch and Facebook and of
course you can follow me on Twitter at
dpacman let me know what you you make of
these numbers
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and Bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa Honey Nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
Maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
I love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but I know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com Pacman the link is down
below